here what what has the field been like
since you guys transition to Las Vegas
ah honestly it it's it's the finals the
playoffs all of that um all inone in
this atmosphere and just this
environment um as y'all can see a lot of
cameras a lot of people it's good it's a
good environment for us did it still
feel like a Lakers environment yeah
definitely a home home crowd for us I
feel like um Vegas being right up the
street so yeah so D when you think about
what you guys are trying to accomplish
this year obviously championship
Inspirations what can you take from the
End season tournament that could kind of
guess help you guys on that mission
later in the
season to be honest it's like a cheat
code you know to get this this feel um
just just for anybody that really hasn't
been this far or just had this
environment um it's almost like a second
round third round type of feel um all
the cameras everybody's watching um it's
Mano imano so you feel like you worked
your way to get to this point for sure
so I think it's a cheat Cod get you this
just this preparation before you get to
that um for real for real when it really
matters in that sense so it's it's cool
to have this Indiana Pacers that's who
you guys are facing in the championship
what's your thoughts on that team and
their style of play and their personnel
H Burton I mean um everything you see
everything he's doing is is is official
so obviously respect to his game and his
style of Play It's allowing a lot of
those other guys to get going as well so
I mean he's the head of the snake
something we got to take care of they're
a fast team they they they score on
makes and misses um how how do you guys
scheme against that um I don't know I
know cam redish is wearing his black Air
Forces so we just going we just going to
we just going to run as as as much as we
can
run